so here's a metaphor imagine you know
1,000 puppies in a in a giant mansion
it's very cute
no you're just running around look at
them but then imagine this that is nasty
security guards who are just cordon off
each room and they don't let the puppies
go from one place to the other so this
is this is the kind of the way the mind
is set up if the mind is not frag if
your mind is not fragmented then the
puppies our thoughts really and our
desires and beliefs and so on
they just roam around freely there's a
certain kind of access to everywhere
whereas if your mind is fragmented then
there are certain parts of your mind
that I just sealed off and then it's
just no communication between some parts
of your mind in some some other parts of
your mind things are kind of information
designers beliefs are put away in this
kind of faraway fragments and kept there
by this nasty security guard so I'm sure
that you can now see what's good here
and what's bad here so not fragmented is
good fragmented is bad so the idea is
that mine can be fragmented in which
case there is no information flow from
certain parts of the mind to certain
other parts of the mind and if your mind
is fragmented then there will be desires
that will conflict with your self-image
and then if you get into a tempting
situation then you're gonna act on it
and she's gonna be finally difficult to
to resist that temptation but if your
mind is not fragmented then you're then
that means that there's your your
various desires are in tune with each
other and they entry with what you think
of yourself and this trait self-control
that I've talked about this measure is
really what it's what it measures what
it's what it reflects is the degree of
your fragmentation of your mind so I
think that the fragmentation of the mind
is a really important thing
independently of the whole temptation
stuff so I'm gonna try to say a little
bit more about fragmentation and then
come back to the to the temptation
business at the end so here is one
really bad news that I have to break to
you at the beginning it's a we're kind
of screwed in the sense that that
fragmentation as a lot of kind of
systemic reasons by fragmentation
the norm another not the exception so
all of our minds are they tend to be
more on the fragmented sided on the non
fragmented side I'm gonna give you three
reasons for that one of them is which I
take to be the most important one is
that we change all of us we change a lot
and most of the time we change in a way
that we don't notice so two very quick
examples one of them is the
mere-exposure effect so if you're
exposed to a certain stimulus whatever
stimulus it is it's going to just by
being exposed to it without any
explanation it's gonna make you like
that kind of stimulus more so if you're
exposed to a certain kind of face or a
certain color that's gonna make you like
that stimulus more and and it's not some
music so if you're exposed to certain
kind of music that's gonna make that
make you like that music more so maybe
you're a you're a fan of early music but
you go to the mall and you you're doing
your shopping and that's Justin Bieber
and on that just by being exposed to
that that's gonna make you like just to
move it a little bit more and it happens
in such a way that you're not aware of
that so may expose you're affecting the
mere-exposure can happen unconsciously
so that's one way in which we change in
the way that we don't notice another way
and that I think is really depressing is
about frustrated desires so we all we
all have we all want things that we
don't get right I mean that happens so
so you you have a desire that gets
frustrated when two things happen you
are want that thing more but when you
achieve it you like it less the want it
more is not very surprising right
because we are always you know if you
fail at something we just want it more
we really want to get won't want to get
that but when you're actually going to
get it because of the previous
frustration you're gonna like it less
and there's beautiful experiments that
will demonstrate this so what what
follows from this is that if you want
something and you and you're not any
kind of consistently not being able to
get it then you're not gonna be able to
enjoy it you're going to something that
you can really care about because you
want to do it it's gonna give you very
little pleasure when you actually
achieve it so you're trained to do the
marathon and you you really want to do
it under three hours and you just can't
and you know it's always three or five
or three or four and then finally you do
it and then you're because of your
previous failures you know
gonna enjoy that much you're going today
okay and that's not what you want I mean
you know you changed your diet you
change your whole daily routine because
of that and then what are you gonna get
the optimist so it said all right so we
change a lot and there's a very nice
experimental evidence for that is at the
end of history illusion and that
measures the the amount of change people
anticipate in the next 10 years compared
to the change they underwent in the last
10 years and it when people consistently
underestimate the change that will
happen to them
so we consider ourselves to be the
finished product that's the end of the
road for us you know we used to be very
different but who I am now
that's that's what I'm gonna be in 20
years and it's just false that's
blatantly false
you